ein dschungelcamp für ganz harte kerle
in thailand lernen soldaten wie sie im
fall der fälle überleben zb indem sie
frisches cobra blut trinken
vorausgesetzt sie wissen wie sie die
gefährliche giftschlange richtig
anpacken das überlebenstraining ist teil
der von den usa und thailand jährlich
abgehaltenen militärübung cobra gut ich
fand's gut dass der thailändische
ausbilder betont hat dass man entweder
gejagter oder jäger ist alles was
unheimlich ist im dunkeln wo man am
gelände angst hat ist normalerweise am
abend das essen auch skorpione sind ein
nahrhafter snack man muss natürlich
wissen wie man den giftstachel entfernt
der geschmack allerdings ist anscheinend
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber wer weiß wie
man feuer macht der kann schlangen und
co ja auch gegrillt genießen soldaten
diese kenntnisse vermitteln auch süße
früchte und essbare pflanzen hält der
dschungel bereit falls gerade mal keine
schlangen oder skorpionen zur hand sind